♪
(Amy)
A lot of people have been
telling me
I look
like Jennifer Lawrence.
I don't see that.
Well, I know I'm taller
than her.
I'm not crazy.
Jim, what's your problem?
I just don't
understand why you guys
would take me here.
Because you
love hot wings.
What are you talking
about right now?
I do,
they're fine,
it's just a guy doesn't want
to come to O'Nutters
right
after a breakup.
Why?
'Cause there are a couple
of good-looking waiters here?
Hey ladies,
how we doing?
Hey.
All right,
hey, excuse me.
My nuts are
down here.
( laughing )
Hey, I'm Amber, welcome
to O'Nutters.
Thanks.
Thank you.
So who's
been here before?
All right, so can I
start anybody off
with a
little pinot greej?
I'll have one.
Yeah, me too.
Can I
have a beer?
Uh, sorry, broham,
no beer,
but we do have skinny girl
white zin spritzers
and if you'd
like, I can 86 the
parasol,
throw in a lemon chunk
for you.
I'll just
have a pinot.
All right, three pinots
for my three pinoteers.
Hey, um.
Normally, I wouldn't risk
getting in trouble,
but you guys
seem super cool.
If I were you, I'd go
for the pitcher,
save you
a few bucks.
Right.
Great tip, thank you.
Let's do it.
You got
it, no problem.
I'm being serious
right now.
You guys
are models, right?
What?
Stop.
Oh my God!
We all
work at Payless.
Oh my God, that's my
favorite shoe store.
Get out.
But you guys should quit
and become models.
I'll be right back
with those pinots, guys.
Thank you.
You got it.
Oh my God.
That was so cool, he told us
about the pitcher deal.
He did not
have to do that.
I should get his number
and have him go out with us
when he gets
off work.
Oh my God.
Wake up.
He's just trying to get
a bigger tip.
Jim, okay,
I know that you're still bummed
about Karen,
but please, don't
just dump your negativity on us.
At work it's one thing,
you know, all the shoes are
around, the people,
but here, on our
time, please get it together.
We have one hour
for lunch,
we're here
to have a great time, okay?
Listen, I don't mean to
eavesdrop on you, brosef,
but you don't want
to end up
like
Rupert over there.
( glass smashing )
Yeah, after his wife
left him,
he went into
a real deep depression.
Got pretty bad.
He forgot how
to live.
So sad.
Don't let that happen
to you, man, okay?
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hey, give
me some nuts.
What?
Give him
some nuts, Jim.
Go on, Jim.
There you go.
A little of this
and a little of that
and you return the favor.
Touch 'em.
Yeah, see?
There you go, huh--
Fun?
So cute.
Yeah.
It feels good, Jim--
It's fun, right?
What did
I just do?
It's good.
Go with it, Jim, don't
ruin this.
You know what,
guys?
I think I have
got just the cure
for senor sad sack
over here.
The check?
( whistling )
Wet nut contest!
( cheering )
Go, go, go!
Woo!
♪
Jim, get up!
Get up!
( victorious yelling )